l'histoire des vaches en cavale en
Mauricie a fait le tour du monde les
bêtes sont récemment rentrés au bercail
mais que faut-il retenir de cet escapade
et que nous a-t-elle appris sur le
comportement animal
les bovins
ne sont pas toujours des vaches en
lactation ce sont plutôt de jeunes
femelles qui ne donnent pas encore de
lait des génisses en gestation de leur
premier veau elles deviennent des torts
une pratique de mettre les jeunesse à
l'extérieur c'est normal c'est une façon
de faire pour les produits
c'est quand même toute une histoire en
Mauricie des résidents essaient de
récupérer des vaches qui se sont
échappées de leur enclos l'été dernier
qu'il y a des animaux qui se sont
échappés soit qui avait un bruit dans le
clôture soit que les animaux manquaient
de nourriture ou même un événement là il
y a les Coyotes il y a certains chiens
des fois des chiens errants et peut
avoir juste le tonnerre la foudre le
bruit excessif sont très sensibles au
bruit si les animaux sillons de la
nourriture qui sont dans la nature qui
sont en groupe la vie est normale mais
il faut les ramener au bercail au plus
vite avant l'hiver
les génisses laitières n'ont pas la
tolérance au froid d'un bœuf de
boucherie
en travaillant dans une sélection qui
amène une certaine aisance pour nous du
côté domestique on a en contrepartie
perdue un peu de la rusticité puis leur
capacité peut être à survivre dans des
situations plus extrêmes donc c'est un
pendant sont venus négatifs de la
domestication mais la domestication
amenait beaucoup plus d'effets positifs
parce que c'est ce qu'on souhaitait
aussi d'avoir des animaux plus dociles
puis sont capables de vivre dans un
environnement entouré d'humain aussi
il y a ces éléments à considérer pour
que le troupeau revienne sain et sauf
d'abord le froid peut être mortel
l'impact négatif du froid c'est surtout
ça c'est la quantité d'énergie que ça va
prendre pour maintenir sa température
corporelle plus de 50 % de notre
température corporelle vient de
l'activité musculaire donc de bouger
puis parce qu'on bouge on dégage de
chaleur pour maintient notre température
corporelle alors si on est sous-alimenté
on mange pas bien on va avoir tendance
plutôt à rester immobile pas trop bouger
sans dormir dans le froid et là on va
devenir hypothermique
la première condition de survie c'est de
bien nourrir l'animal
qui mange ça fait beau mien ou du sel on
est dans les bovins laitiers où il faut
des fourrages puis même l'hiver à cause
du foie déconcentré quelque chose de
plus riche
la deuxième condition du survie l'animal
doit avoir un abri il faut qu'il y a
accès aussi à un endroit pour s'abriter
lors des tempêtes donc on peut parler de
brise-vent ou de l'intérieur d'une forêt
mais on peut pas le laisser au coeur de
la tempête et on lui a donné du temps
pour faire son pelage d'hiver donc il
n'y a pas été soudainement au froid mais
il y a été progressivement vers le froid
même si c'est pas le numéro 1 là je
pense que tout ce qu'il faut pour passer
au travers
le beauvalier est un animal grégaire
juste l'aspect psychologique si on veut
jusqu'à un certain point il y a toute
l'aspect aussi de pouvoir se réchauffer
un peu puis de s'alimenter en groupe
puis de se sentir mieux puis d'enlever
un effet de stress il a été isolé c'est
toujours plus stressant pour un animal
qui est habitué de vivre en groupe parce
que la sécurité a bien de l'effet de
groupe ce qu'on peut voir c'est qu'il
retourne assez vite dans leur état
sauvage le camp qui ont plus de contact
avec l'humain mais c'est les bovins
c'est une des facultés c'est qu'ils
apprennent vraiment vite il s'adapte
aussi
comment s'y prendre pour attirer le
troupeau à l'étable
on les ramène on les rapproche en les
offrant de la nourriture puis comme ça
en vient de plus en plus près des
bâtiments puis on peut faire un entrelos
puis pouvoir les revoir avec nous par la
suite ça peut prendre du temps le
positionnement l'animal avec sa vision
360 nous voit toujours en arrière on se
concentre seulement sur le devant du
groupe puis on guide le devant du groupe
on se positionnant le reste du troupeau
va suivre
comment s'y prendre pour réapprivoiser
le troupeau
des ramener mais des laisser dans un
environnement où on encloit assez grand
pour leur donner la liberté de mouvement
puis pour avoir le moins de changement
possible
d'essayer d'éliminer le plus de stress
possible donc faut pas parler fort
ne pas bouger rapidement y aller de
façon calme les récompenser avec de la
nourriture donc tout ce qui est
traitement positif va faire qu'on va les
ramener puis vont se rééduquer à être
avec l'humain puis à côtoyer l'humain de
façon normale
[Musique]